This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Many scientists who study people end up saying some version of the following sentence. The human being is the only animal that has a sense of humor. That can cooperate. That do radio shows. That regularly fashion and use tools. That have. Chins.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·韦丹塔姆。许多研究人类的科学家最终都会说出以下某种版本的话。人类是唯一有幽默感的动物。会合作。会做广播节目。会定期制作和使用工具。有。下巴。
Psychologist Daniel Gilbert at Harvard University finishes the sentence this way. The human being is the only animal that thinks about the future. Every animal learns from trial and error. Human beings learn from experiences they've never even had. They close their eyes and say, what I like to live in on your ice cream, yuck. Would it be a good idea to put my finger in a pencil sharpener? No. But just because we humans have great imaginations,
哈佛大学的心理学家丹尼尔·吉尔伯特用这种方式完成了这句话。人类是唯一思考未来的动物。每种动物都通过试错来学习。人类则从他们从未经历过的体验中学习。他们闭上眼睛说，我喜欢住在你的冰淇淋里吗？真恶心。把手指放进卷笔刀是个好主意吗？不。但仅仅因为我们人类有伟大的想象力，
it doesn't mean we do a good job of predicting the future accurately. People just aren't very good at looking into their future and predicting correctly their emotional reactions to the events that might unfold. We think a dentist appointment will be awful, and then it's not so bad. We think buying a new car will be awful, and then it's not so bad. We think buying a new car will make us very happy, but a dentist being just nice.
并不意味着我们在准确预测未来方面做得很好。人们就是不擅长展望未来，并不准确地预测他们对可能展开的事件的情绪反应。我们认为看牙医会很糟糕，然后发现其实没那么糟。我们认为买一辆新车会很糟糕，然后发现其实没那么糟。我们认为买一辆新车会让我们非常高兴，而看牙医只是很好。
We think losing a job is the worst thing that could happen to us, and then it becomes the best thing. The problem is once our minds get to work imagining the future, we leave out important details, like the nice lady at the front desk in the dentist office or the free toothbrush. When I think about the future, I also don't consider the fact that I'm going to be a different person in the future, someone who may want to minivan instead of a convertible. Most of us also underestimate how good we are at rationalizing the decisions that we make. Joining me today to talk about our foggy foresight, and what we can do to make it better,
我们认为失业是我们可能遭遇的最糟糕的事情，然后它却变成了最好的事。问题是，一旦我们的大脑开始想象未来，我们就遗漏了重要的细节，比如牙医诊所前台那位态度很好的女士或免费牙刷。当我考虑未来时，我也没有考虑到这样一个事实：我在未来会变成一个不同的人，一个可能想要小型货车而不是敞篷车的人。我们大多数人还低估了我们在合理化自己所做决定方面的能力。今天和我一起探讨我们模糊的远见，以及我们能做些什么来改善它的，
is psychologist Daniel Gilbert. He's the author of the book, Stumbling on Happiness, and one of my favorite researchers in the world. Dan, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, you're not my favorite radio host in the world. Well, that was easy. I want to start by asking you a question that you and I talked about a while ago, Dan. Some years ago, you went through a series
是心理学家丹尼尔·吉尔伯特。他是《撞上快乐》一书的作者，也是我世界上最喜欢的研究人员之一。丹，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢，你可不是我世界上最喜欢的广播主持人。好吧，这很容易。我想先问你一个你和我不久前讨论过的问题，丹。几年前，你经历了一系列
of very difficult personal experiences, but instead of leaving you broken-hearted as you might have anticipated, it left you with actually a very important insight into your own ability to predict your future emotional states. Can you tell me what happened? Well, my personal experiences were no worse than the average person's, in fact, better than most. But like everybody, I suffer the slings and arrows about rage's fortune. We have divorces, we have surgeries, we have breakups with women we love and friends we enjoy. So it was sort of ordinary events that befell me all in one year. And I realized that had you asked me a year earlier how I would be fairing, the answer would have been, oh my gosh, I'll be devastated. But I wasn't devastated, it wasn't a good year, but it was okay. And it made me wonder if I was the only person who was just too stupid
非常困难的个人经历，但它没有像你预期的那样让你心碎，反而让你对预测自己未来情绪状态的能力有了非常重要的深刻见解。你能告诉我发生了什么吗？嗯，我的个人经历并不比普通人差，事实上比大多数人都要好。但像每个人一样，我承受着命运暴虐的投枪和箭矢。我们有离婚，我们有手术，我们有与我们所爱的女人和我们喜欢的朋克的分手。所以这些都是降临在我身上的普通事件，而且都在一年内发生。我意识到，如果你在一年前问我我会有多好，答案会是，哦天哪，我会崩溃的。但我没有崩溃，这不是好的一年，但还过得去。这让我怀疑我是不是唯一一个太蠢
to be able to look ahead into his future and figure out how he'd feel if really bad or maybe really good things happened. So I went to the laboratory and teamed up with my friend Tim Wilson and we started studying this phenomenon. And you know reassuringly we found out we weren't the only stupid people out there. You've also found that painful decisions are often painful, largely because we haven't made them yet. Once we actually make a decision, pick one of two alternatives, we often end up wondering how we could ever have dreamed of choosing the other choice. Well, surely that's true for all of us.
以至于无法展望未来并弄清楚如果发生非常糟糕或非常好的事情自己会有什么感觉的人。所以我去了实验室，和我的朋友蒂姆·威尔逊合作，我们开始研究这种现象。你知道，令人安心的是，我们发现我们并不是外面仅有的笨蛋。你还发现痛苦的决定往往是痛苦的，很大程度上是因为我们还没有做出决定。一旦我们真正做出了决定，在两个选项中选择一个，我们常常最终会想，我们怎么可能做梦也没想到会选择另一个选项。嗯，对我们所有人来说，这当然是真的。
We agonize between two things that seem awfully close. We finally choose one. And in a small or medium amount of time, we look back and wonder how we could ever have been trying to decide between them. Why did we make that mistake of thinking the two alternatives were so close when in fact, they were really far apart?
我们在两个看起来非常接近的事情之间痛苦挣扎。我们最终选择了一个。在一段短或中等的时间内，我们回过头来想，我们怎么会曾经试图在它们之间做出决定。为什么我们会犯这种错误，认为这两个替代方案如此接近，而实际上，它们相距甚远呢？
The answer is they weren't really close and they weren't really far apart. It's just a matter of how you look at it. And when you're on the front side of a decision, alternatives seem to be very close, but once you've chosen one, the mind gets going, doing what the mind does so well. Convincing you that the thing you've got is better than the thing you've left behind. Now if psychologists are trying to cure that, we call it rationalization. If we're trying to sell it, we call it coping. But whether you call it coping or rationalization, it's the same thing. It's the mind-finding
答案是它们既不是真的很近，也不是真的很远。这只是你看待它的方式问题。当你处于决策的前端时，替代方案似乎非常接近，但一旦你选择了一个，大脑就开始运转，做大脑最擅长的事。说服你，你拥有的东西比你抛在脑后的东西更好。现在，如果心理学家试图治愈它，我们称之为合理化。如果我们试图推销它，我们称之为应对。但无论你称之为应对还是合理化，它们都是同一回事。这是大脑在寻找
realistic ways to see the world so that it feels better about the world in which it finds itself. You want subscribe to the very popular belief that I think I still subscribe to that more freedom always equals more happiness. And if I remember correctly, you conducted a study once that found that this wasn't quite right. And at the time, I think you told me that you'd been living with your girlfriend for more than a decade. And you saw the data and you decided to make some changes in your life. You have a very good memory. So like many people, I used to believe that the more freedom, the better. How could you be less happy when you had more choice?
看待世界的现实方式，以便对它所处的这个世界感觉更好。你是否赞同那个非常受欢迎的观点——我认为我仍然赞同——即更多的自由总是等于更多的快乐。如果我没记错的话，你曾经做过一项研究，发现这并不完全正确。当时，我想你告诉我，你和你的女朋友已经同居了十多年。你看到了数据，决定改变你的生活。你记性真好。所以像许多人一样，我曾经相信，自由越多越好。当你拥有更多选择时，你怎么可能不那么快乐呢？
Well we know now a lot about why more choice sometimes makes people less happy. In our study, we brought students in and we created a photography course and we had all of them work with us for a long time learning how to do black and white photography. Then at the end of the course we gave them two photographs that they had taken and we said they could keep one and we were going to keep one. Well this was horrible for them. They wanted to keep both. They had a tough decision to make. In one group we said, if you ever change your mind about which photograph you want, just let us know. We'll swap with you. We're going to keep this unfile forever. So if you took A and you want B, we'll swap B for A for as long as we both shall live. Another group was told your decision is final. Once you make this decision, the photograph
好吧，关于为什么更多的选择有时会让人们不那么快乐，我们现在了解了很多。在我们的研究中，我们把学生带进来，我们开设了一个摄影课程，我们让所有人都和我们一起工作很长时间，学习如何进行黑白摄影。然后在课程结束时，我们给了他们两张他们拍的照片，我们说他们可以保留一张，我们要保留一张。嗯，这对他们来说太糟糕了。他们想两张都留着。他们面临着艰难的决定。在一个小组中，我们说，如果你改变了对你想要的哪张照片的主意，只要告诉我们。我们会跟你换。我们将永远把这个存档。所以如果你拿了A想要B，只要我们都还活着，我们就用B换A。另一组被告知你的决定是最终的。一旦你做出这个决定，照片
that you're donating to us gets sent off to England. It'll never be seen again. And of course, if you presented those choices to me, I would say I would want to be in the first group because I would preserve my options if I took a photograph home and didn't like it, I could come back and trade it in for the one that I did like. Exactly, and that's not even just a good guess. We actually did exactly that in another study. We asked people which group they wanted to be in and just like you, they overwhelmingly want to be in the first group. But what's interesting is we tracked the happiness of the people who had made these decisions over the course of several weeks. And what we found is that people who made
你捐赠给我们的照片将被运往英国。它将再也见不到天日了。当然，如果你把这些选择摆在我面前，我会说我想留在第一组，因为我会保留我的选择，如果我带回家一张照片却不喜欢它，我可以回来把它换成我喜欢的。没错，这甚至不仅仅是一个好的猜测。我们在另一项研究中确实完全做到了这一点。我们问人们他们想加入哪个小组，就像你一样，他们压倒性地想加入第一组。但有趣的是，我们追踪了在几周内做出这些决定的人们的快乐程度。我们发现，做出
an irrevocable decision, one they couldn't change, were much happier with the choice they made. When you've made an irrevocable decision, you rationalize it. Once something's gone and gone forever, the mind gets to work figuring out why, what it got is really better than what it lost. But when a decision isn't irrevocable, when you can remake it and revisit it and change your mind anytime, what do you do? You just ruminate about it, right? You buy a sweater and you know you can take it back anytime and every time you put it on, you look in the mirror and you think, I don't know, maybe it's not a good fit, maybe it's not a good color, maybe I ought to bring it back.
不可撤销决定（他们无法改变的决定）的人，对他们做出的选择要快乐得多。当你做出不可撤销的决定时，你会将其合理化。一旦某事消失了并且永远消失了，大脑就开始工作，弄清楚为什么它得到的东西真的比失去的东西更好。但是，当一个决定不是不可撤销的，当你随时可以重新做出、重新审视并改变主意时，你会怎么做？你只是对此反刍，对吧？你买了一件毛衣，你知道你随时可以退货，每次你穿上它，你照着镜子想，我不知道，也许它不太合身，也许颜色不好，也许我应该把它拿回去。
On the other hand, if this sweater was bought at a place that won't take it back, you look in the mirror and you say, gosh, that looks good. So you took this research and you applied it to your own life? I did, I think my then girlfriend and I had been living together for about a decade. And once we saw the results of this experiment, and a friend of mine, Dave Myers called and said, you know, I think this really explains the difference between living together and getting married, which had never occurred to me. I thought, you know, if you're a scientist and you don't live by your own results, what
另一方面，如果这件毛衣是在一个不接受退货的地方买的，你照着镜子说，天哪，这看起来真不错。所以你把这项研究应用到了你自己的生活中？是的，我想我和当时的女友已经同居了大约十年。一旦我们看到了这个实验的结果，我的一个朋友戴夫·迈尔斯打电话说，你知道，我认为这真的解释了同居和结婚的区别，这我以前从未想到过。我想，你知道，如果你是一个科学家，却不按自己的研究结果生活，你
kind of scientist are you? So yeah, I went home and proposed. And guess what? I was utterly right. I love her so much more now that we're married. Now that I can't get out of this relationship no matter how fast I run, she is the love of my life. And I didn't realize that when I was always thinking, should I stay or shouldn't I stay? There's a lot to be said for making commitments.
算什么科学家？所以是的，我回家求婚了。你猜怎么着？我完全是对的。现在我们结婚了，我比以前更爱她了。无论我跑得有多快，我都无法摆脱这段关系，她是我一生的挚爱。当我总是想着我该留下来还是不该留下来时，我并没有意识到这一点。做出承诺大有可为。
So let's talk a little bit about why these errors often happen. One idea that you've explored is that when we imagine the future, we often fail to take into account all the little details that will actually make us happy or sad. Well, it's true. Every future event comprises thousands and thousands of details, but when you ask people to imagine a future event, they usually imagine one or two of those details, the ones that are central that define the episode. So if I say to you, imagine the next visit to the dentist. Probably you get a picture in your head instantly of sitting in a chair and someone's fooling
所以让我们多谈谈为什么这些错误经常发生。你探讨过的一个观点是，当我们想象未来时，我们经常无法把所有那些实际上会让我们快乐或悲伤的小细节考虑在内。嗯，确实如此。每个未来的事件都包含成千上万的细节，但当你要求人们想象一个未来的事件时，他们通常会想象其中的一两个细节，那些定义该情节的核心细节。所以如果我对你说了，想象下一次看牙医。可能你的脑海里会立刻浮现出坐在椅子上，有人在你的嘴里摆弄的画面。嗯，这确实是你将要经历的一部分体验。但你还得停车，你还会在候诊室里，他们会放音乐，会有杂志。接待员态度好不好。之后，你将有或没有预约。你需要赶时间。体验中还有很多其他部分你没有想象到。所有这些都会影响你的快乐。
around in your mouth. Well that is indeed a part of the experience you'll have. But you also have to park, you're also going to be in the waiting room, they're going to be playing music, there will be magazines. The receptionist will be nice or not. Afterwards, you will or won't have an appointment. You need to rush to. There's lots of other parts of that experience that you're not imagining. And all of them can affect your happiness.
现在你无法想象每一个细节。那是不可能的。但你理应做的是对自己说，我只想象了这体验众多片段中的一两个，因此，对于我的预测，我应该非常谦虚。但没有人这么做。相反，他们说，看牙医？哦，讨厌。
Now you can't imagine every detail. That's not possible. But what you ought to do rationally is think to yourself, I'm only imagining one or two of the many pieces of the experience, and as a result, I should be very humble about my prediction. But nobody is. Instead, they say, a dental visit? Oh, hate it.
你在这一系列研究中发现的最有趣的事情之一是，不仅仅是我们没有在所有的饱满和细节中想象未来的事件，我们也没有充分认识到，到那时候我们可能不再是我们现在这样的人了。你知道，我认为这是这两个错误中更强大的一个。所以你说得完全对，一个问题是我们没有正确想象事件。我们没有按照它们将要展开的方式去想象它们。这是两个问题中较小的一个。
One of the most interesting things you found in this line of research is that it's not just that we don't imagine the event in the future in all its fullness and detail, we also don't fully appreciate that we might not quite be the same people we are then that we are now. You know, I think that's even the more powerful of the two errors. So you're quite right, one problem is that we don't imagine events correctly. We don't imagine them as they will unfold. That's the smaller of the two problems.
更大的问题是，我们不知道当我们经历该事件时我们会是谁。我们低估了大脑以不同于其在展望时反应的方式对事件做出反应的能力。你知道，从挡风玻璃看出去和从后视镜看进去，事情看起来是不一样的。生活也是如此。几乎你经历的每一个事件，一旦你经历过了，感觉就会与你事先想象的不同。那是我们心理学的一部分。我们似乎不太擅长预料这一点。我是否记得你最近做的一项研究，它在人们的
The larger problem is that we don't know who we will be when we are experiencing that event. We underestimate the minds ability to react to events in a different way than it's reacting to them in prospect. You know, things look different from out the windshield and in the rear view mirror. Life is like that too. Almost every event you experience feels different once you've experienced it, then you imagined it would have beforehand. That's the part of our psychology. We don't seem very good at anticipating. Do I recall a study that you did recently which tracked people over the course of their
一生中追踪他们，问他们如何想象自己在未来会如何改变，以及他们过去是如何改变的？你记得很准。我们最近发表了一篇论文，表明当人们被要求预测他们在未来会改变多少时，他们低估了这一点。听着，我们都知道18岁的年轻人很疯狂。他们认为自己就是自己。他们会永远保持那种状态。
lives and asked them how they imagined they would change in the future versus how they had changed in the past? You are remembering correctly. We recently published a paper showing that when people are asked to predict how much they will change in the future, they underestimate it. Look, we all know 18-year-olds are crazy. They think they are who they are. They're going to be that way forever.
他们有着疯狂的发型和纹身，他们相信自己会在余生中都想要这些。像我这样上了年纪的人会窃笑并说，走着瞧吧。因为18岁的年轻人低估了他们在28岁时会有多大不同。我们在实验中通过让18岁的年轻人告诉我们他们在未来10年里会改变多少，以及让28岁的年轻人告诉我们在过去10年里他们改变了多少来证明这一点。在一个完全理性的世界里，这些数字应该是相同的，但事实并非如此。18岁的年轻人认为他们只会改变一点点。28岁的年轻人则报告说
They have crazy hairstyles and tattoos that they believe they're going to want for the rest of their lives. And old people like me snicker and go, you're going to see. Because 18-year-olds underestimate how different they're going to be when they're 28. And we showed this in our experiment by asking 18-year-olds to tell us how much they would change in the next 10 years, and asking 28-year-olds to tell us how much they had changed in the last 10 years. In a perfectly rational world, those numbers would be the same and they weren't. 18-year-olds thought they would change very little. 28-year-olds reported
自己改变了很多。但这项研究如此有趣的地方在于，对于58岁和68岁的人来说也是如此。也就是说，58岁的人会想，好吧，我完了。我定型了。就还是我，可能稍微发福一点，皱纹多一点，但我就是我将要成为的那个人。68岁的人回顾过去10年说，哇，我变了多少啊。所以丹，真正令人着迷的是，无论我们在生活中经历这些错误多少次，无论我们犯了多少次同样的错误，不知何故，我们就是没有从中吸取教训，我们依然保持着和以前一样的自信，即现在，这一次，当我预测未来时，我会是对的。错误有两种。有时你开车去某地，你走错了路，下一次你总是
having changed a lot. But what's so interesting about the study is it's also true with 58-year-olds and 68-year-olds. That is, 58-year-olds think, okay, I'm done. I'm cooked. It'll just be me, maybe a little flabier, more wrinkles, but I'm the guy I'm going to be. 68-year-olds look back to the last 10 years and say, wow, have I changed? So what's really fascinating about this Dan is that no matter how many times we experience these errors in our lives and how many times we make the same mistakes, somehow we don't learn from them and we're left with the same confidence that we had before that now, this time, when I predict the future, I'm going to be right. There are two kinds of errors. Sometimes you're driving some place and you take the wrong route, the next time you always
能走对。但还有一些错误更像是光学错觉。你知道，你看到页面上的那两条平行线，然后你说，天哪，在我看来它们不像平行的，然后你测量它们，然后你说，天哪，在我看来它们不像平行的。然后你测量它们，它们确实是平行的，但当你退后一步看时，它们看起来又不像了。所以你再次测量它们，它们确实是平行的，但它们看起来依然不像。我认为我们正在讨论的这种错误有点像光学错觉。你情不自禁地以这种有缺陷的方式看待未来。
get it right. But then there are errors that are more like, oh, optical illusions. You know, you see those two parallel lines on the page and you say, gosh, they don't look parallel to me and then you measure them and you say, gosh, they don't look parallel to me. And then you measure them and they are, but then you stand back and they don't look that way. So you measure them again, but they are, but they keep not looking that way. I think the kinds of errors we're talking about are a little bit more like optical illusions. You can't help but see the future in this deficient way.
一次又一次，你会发现你的预测是错误的，并且一次又一次你会做出相同的预测。当我们回来时，我要问丹，我们如何利用他的研究见解来帮助我们做出更有可能让我们在未来更快乐的决定。请继续收听。我请丹告诉我，他是否找到了帮助人们利用想象力为未来的自己做出更好决策的方法。我们和许多其他人花了数十年时间试图弄清楚，我们如何才能让人类的想象力变得更好。如果人们在展望未来时会犯错误。
Time and time again, you will find your predictions were wrong and time and time again you'll make the same predictions. When we come back I'm going to ask Dan how we can use insights from his research to help us make decisions that are more likely to make us happier in the future. Stay with us. I asked Dan to tell me whether he's found ways to help people use their imaginations, to make better decisions for their future selves. We and many others have spent decades trying to figure out how can we make human imagination better. If when people look into the future, they make mistakes.
我们可以对他们进行什么样的培训，让他们不会犯这些错误？我将向你总结15年的研究成果。没用。几乎任何人尝试过的东西都没有产生持久的、广泛的影响。另一方面，我们发现预测未来的最好方法不是闭上眼睛发挥你的想象力。有一种完全不同的方式来弄清楚你会有什么感觉，那就是去问那些已经身处你未来的人他们感觉如何。几乎你想象的任何事情，我应该搬到夏威夷吗，我应该成为一个
What kind of training could we give them so they don't make these mistakes? And I will give you the summary of 15 years of research. It doesn't work. Almost nothing anybody has ever tried makes a long-lasting, broad difference. On the other hand, the best way to predict your future we've discovered is not to close your eyes and use your imagination. There is a completely different way to figure out how you will feel, and that is to ask people who are already in your future how they feel. Almost anything you're imagining, should I move to Hawaii, should I become a
小号手吗？我想知道我是否应该订阅《纽约时报》，吃贝果还是吃比尔更好？几乎你正在辩论的任何决定，无论大小，许多人已经做出了决定，而且他们是在两个方向上都做过。有些人正在做你只在想象的事情。事实证明，如果你能简单地衡量他们的快乐程度，你就可以对你在未来会有多快乐得到一个相当不错的指导。我们做的最简单地证明这一点的实验之一是，我们创建了一个快速约会诊所
trumpet player? I wonder if I should subscribe to the New York Times would it be better to have a bagel or a beale? Almost any decision you're debating, large or small, many people have already made it, and they've made it in both directions. There are people who are doing the things you're only imagining. And it turns out that if you can simply measure their happiness, you can get a pretty good guide about how happy you will be in the future. One of the experiments that we did that demonstrated this most simply is we created a speed dating clinic
年轻女性进来，和一位年轻男性进行快速约会。她们被提供两种信息中的一种。要么她们可以在见面之前了解关于这个年轻男子的所有信息，她们可以看到他的照片，了解他的爱好，了解他的喜好和厌恶，或者她们可以在见面之前了解关于这个年轻男子的所有信息，她们可以看到他的照片，了解他的爱好，了解他的喜好和厌恶，或者她们可以完全不了解这些，而只能得到一条信息，即：已经和他进行过快速约会的女性有多享受这段经历？
where young women came in and they had a speed date with a young man. And they were offered one of two kinds of information. Either they could learn all about the young man before they met him, they could see his photograph, learn his hobbies, find out about his likes and his dislikes, or they could learn all about the young man before they met him, they could see his photograph, learn his hobbies, find out about his likes and his dislikes, or they could learn none of that and they could get just one piece of information, namely, how much did the woman who already had a speed date with him enjoy it?
嗯，事实证明，首先，每个人都想要第一种信息。我们研究中的女性都认为，如果她们能了解那个男人的情况，她们就能对自已会有多享受这次约会做出好得多的预测。但我们发现，如果她们除了另一个女性的经验之外一无所知，她们在预测自己的体验时会准确得多。在某种程度上，这个女性是她们未来自已的替代者，我们称这种方法为替代法——使用别人的经验作为你自己的指南。所以基本上有一个基于这个想法的商业应用。
Well, it turns out, first of all, everybody wants the first kind of information. Women in our study all think they're going to make a much better prediction of how much they'll enjoy the date if they can just learn about the guy. But what we find is that they're much more accurate in predicting their own experience if they know nothing except another woman's experience. This woman is in a sense a surrogate for their future selves, and we call this method surrogation using other people's experiences as a guide to your own. So there's a commercial application basically is built on this idea.
它叫Yelp。完全正确。在少数几个领域，我们都知道我们想要依赖别人的评论，如果你愿意的话。电影和餐馆，这是两个大领域。现在为什么我们愿意在这些领域依赖别人？因为我们自己无法想象。我的意思是，如果我说你觉得你有多享受这家新餐馆，你看着我说，我怎么可能闭上眼睛想象那个？当我们没有任何关于未来事件的信息
It's called Yelp. Exactly right. And there are a few domains in which we all know that we want to rely on other people's reviews, if you will. Movies and restaurants, those are the two big domains. Now why are we willing to rely on other people in these domains? Because we can't imagine for ourselves. I mean, if I say how much do you think you'll enjoy the new restaurant, you look at me and go, how can I possibly close my eyes and imagine that? When we have no information
时，我们成了替代法的追随者。我们愿意听取别人的意见。但如果你给人们提供关于未来事件的哪怕是最小的一点信息，他们也会接受它，而不是所有的Yelp评论。所以让我问你，你打算决定是否花很多钱买一部电影。你宁愿看预告片还是宁愿阅读评论？如果你像大多数人一样，你会扔掉世界上所有影评人和所有助手的评论
about a future event, we become surrogators. We're willing to listen to other people. But if you offer folks, even the smallest piece of information about a future event, they will take that over all the Yelp reviews. So let me ask you, you're going to decide whether to spend a lot of money to buy a movie. Would you rather see the trailer or would you rather read reviews? If you're like most people, you would throw out all the reviews by every critic and every helper in the world
如果你能只看预告片，因为你在某种程度上比别人更信任你自己的判断。你觉得如果你能只品尝30秒、60秒的电影，你就会知道这是否是你喜欢的电影，但你不会。别人的评论将是很好的信息，
if you could just see the trailer because you trust your own judgment in some ways better than others. You feel if you could just taste 30 seconds, 60 seconds of the movie, you'll know if it's the kind of movie you like, but you won't. Other people's reviews are going to be great information
关于诸如电影是不是太长了？情节变得可预测了吗？上帝最后是不是从机器里出来了？诸如此类你在预告片中永远无法获得的东西。然而，如果你给人们提供这两种信息，每一次他们都会选择预告片。那么你是否会建议我们实际上应该
about things like, did the movie go on too long? Did the plot get predictable? Did God come out of a machine in the end? about things like, did the movie go on too long? Did the plot get predictable? Did God come out of a machine in the end? All sorts of things you'll never get from a trailer. And yet, if you offer people these two kinds of information, the trailer every time. So would you suggest that we should actually have
对所有事情都有Yelp，我们应该对我们的朋友、配偶、孩子和教授进行评分？全通过这种分布式评论系统？嗯，作为一个教授，我确实已经得到了评分，所以有一个针对我的评论系统。在哈佛，我们有一个古老的传统。它被称为选课周。在开学第一周，
Yelp for everything, that we should be rating our friends and spouses and children and professors? All via this kind of distributed review system? Well, as a professor, I do get rated already, so there is a review system for me. And at Harvard, we have a quaint tradition. It's called Shopping Week. And in the first week of school,
所有的学生都进来旁听课程。他们不会提前选择他们的课程。他们去旁听所有课程，看15到20分钟的讲座，因为他们确信，学校管理层也确信，他们可以通过某人20分钟的讲座看出他们是否会真正喜欢这门课并从中收获很多。他们忽视的是来自真正坐在这个课堂上15周的人的大量信息数据库
all the students come in and they visit classes. They don't choose their classes ahead of time. They visit them all to see 15 or 20 minutes of a lecture because they're convinced, and the administration is convinced, that they can tell from 20 minutes of someone's lecture whether they'll really enjoy and get a lot out of the class. What they're ignoring is a huge database of information from people who actually sat through the class for 15 weeks
并且有很多话要说，关于你是否会喜欢它。你无法说服一个学生去上一门评价很好的课，如果他们不喜欢第一节课的10分钟的话。问题是我们所说的多样性错觉。我们认为自己是完全独一无二的，别人的经验可能会告诉我们一点关于我们自己的信息，但不会太多，因为毕竟，我们和每个人都太不一样了。胡说八道，你并不和每个人都不一样，我们基本上都是一样的。你知道，如果一个火星人知道关于地球上一个人类所能知道的一切，
and have a whole lot to say about whether you'll enjoy it or not. You can't convince a student to take a class that has great reviews if they didn't like the 10 minutes of the first lecture. The problem is something we call the illusion of diversity. We think we are utterly unique that other people's experiences might tell us a little bit about ours, but not very much because after all, we're so different than everybody. Well nonsense, you're not different than everybody, we're basically all the same. You know, if a Martian knew everything there was to know, everything there was to know
关于地球上一个人类所能知道的一切，那个火星人就会知道地球上每个人所需要知道的90%的事情。我必须稍微反驳一下，因为我也认为，心理学部门的同事可能进行了大量的研究，发现这些评论也充满了各种偏见。例如，女教授得到的评价比男教授差得多，尽管她们同样优秀。我的意思是，当大众实际上完全有能力产生集体偏见时，将你的判断外包给大众，难道没有风险吗？
about a single human being on Earth, that Martian would know 90% of what there is to know about everybody on Earth. I have to push back just a little bit because there's also been, I think, a voluminous research conducted by maybe colleagues in the psychology department, which finds that these reviews are also shot through with all kinds of biases. So female professors, for example, get much worse reviews than male professors when they're just as good. I mean, isn't there a risk in essentially outsourcing your judgment to the crowd when the crowd actually is capable fully of having collective biases.
关于这一点，首先有两点要说：如果你和评论者的偏见相同，他们就会准确预测你的感觉，即使这是不公平的。假设你就是不喜欢像我这样的老家伙。假设存在某种偏见。学生们受不了听一个50多岁的人喋喋不休。
Well, two things to say about this first, if you share the biases of the reviewers, they will correctly predict how you will feel, even if it's unfair. So let's say you just don't like old guys like me. Let's say there's a bias. Students can't stand to hear a guy in his 50s, Yammer and Yammer.
嗯，这不是很公平，这是年龄歧视，这是不对的。另一方面，当学生们说我讨厌它时，对于另一个可能会因为所有相同原因而讨厌它的18岁年轻人来说，这是一个相当不错的指南。我要说的第二点是：我并不是说替代法是做出决定的完美方式。你知道，温斯顿·除了其他方式之外，丘吉尔曾说过，
Well, that's not very fair, that's Aegis, that's wrong. On the other hand, when the students say I hated it, it's a pretty good guide for another 18-year-old who will probably hate it for all the same reasons. The second point I'd make is this, I'm not saying that surrogation is a perfect way to make decisions. You know, Winston Churchill once said,
民主是最糟糕的政府形式。好吧，替代法是预测你未来自身幸福的一种糟糕方式，除了其他预测方式之外。你知道，想象力是如此完全有缺陷，以至于替代法，即使有所有的问题，结果也证明是一种比那更好的方法。现在，如果有第三种方法来做出这些决定，我非常愿意听取，但我们从未发现过它。
democracy is the worst form of government, except for the others. Well, surrogation is a terrible way to make predictions about your own future happiness, except for the other way to make predictions. You know, imagination is so utterly flawed that surrogation, even with all of its problems, turns out to be a better method than that. Now, if there's a third way to make them, I'm very open to hearing about it, but we've never discovered it.
你和其他人发现的另一个观点是，不确定性可以放大事件的情感效力，快乐的惊喜和不快乐的惊喜比我们知道会发生的快乐事情和我们知道会发生的悲伤事情对我们产生更大的影响。这是为什么，我们能从中学到什么？嗯，毫无疑问，不确定性可以放大情绪。所以如果我告诉你有什么不好的事情要发生了，它可能不会像偶然发生时那么糟糕，好的事件也是如此。
One other idea that you and others have found is that uncertainty can amplify the emotional potency of events that happy surprises and unhappy surprises make a bigger impact on us than happy things that we know are going to happen and sad things that we know are going to happen. Why is this and how can we learn from it? Well there's no doubt that uncertainty can amplify emotions. So if I tell you something bad is about to happen, it's probably not going to be quite as bad as if it happens by surprise, and the same is true of good events.
我们已经知道这一点几十年了，甚至几个世纪了，这不是一个特别深刻的观察。我们觉得真正有趣的是，尽管这是真的，但人们从不想要不确定性。他们回避它。他们花好钱来避免它。我们做了一项研究，人们观看了一部电影，对于我们实验中的一些人，我们没有让他们观看电影是如何结局的。我们没有让他们看到主角发生了什么。然而，我问你，这两部电影你更愿意看哪一部，百分之百的人举起手说，请看电影的结局。但我们
We've known that for decades, if not centuries, and that's not a particularly deep observation. What we found really interesting is that even though this is true, people never want uncertainty. They issue it. They pay good money not to have it. We did a study in which people watched a movie, and for some of the people in our experiment, we didn't let them watch how the movie ended. We didn't let them see what happened to the main character. However, I asked you, which of these two movies would you rather see, a hundred percent of the hands go up and said, like to see the end of the movie, please. But what
发现的是，那些没有看到电影结局的人更喜欢它，思考的时间更长，或者仍然投入其中，甚至在几小时或几天后仍然在享受它。他们没有看到最后发生了什么，主角最终如何，所以他们一直想知道，天哪，我想知道他是去上大学了还是成了足球运动员。这是一件多么有趣的事情去思考和享受。所以，关键是，一点点的不确定性可以让你非常快乐，但我们似乎永远不想要它。如果明天鲜花出现在你的门口，没有便条，只有一个秘密崇拜者，我敢打赌你会付给我很多钱来找出
we discovered was, people who didn't see the end of the movie liked it more, thought about it for longer, or still engaged in it, and still enjoying it, even hours or days later. They didn't see what happened the last, the main character in the end, and so they kept wondering, gosh, I wonder if he went to college or he became a football player. What an interesting thing to be thinking about and enjoying. So, the point is that a little bit of uncertainty can make you very happy, but we never seem to want it. If flowers showed up on your doorstep tomorrow, with no note, just said secret admirer, I bet you'd pay me a lot to find
谁是那个秘密崇拜者，但我向你保证，无论他是谁，有一个秘密崇拜者总比知道是谁送的花要好。当涉及到积极事件时，你是否真的尝试并积极地在自己的生活中建立神秘感？我不告诉你。哈哈哈哈。丹，我想谢谢你今天和我交谈。这真的很愉快。当然，对我来说也很愉快。谢谢。本期《隐藏的大脑》由马克斯·内斯特拉克制作，珍妮·施密特编辑。我们的工作人员还包括玛吉·彭曼、克里斯·本德雷夫和卡拉·麦格克-艾利森。
out who the secret admirer was, but I guarantee you no matter who it is, it's better off just having a secret admirer than knowing who sent the flowers. Do you actually try and actively build mystery into your own life when it comes to positive events? I'm not telling. Hahaha. Dan, I want to thank you for talking with me today. This has really been fun. Sure, been fun for me too. Thank you. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Max Nestrak and edited by Jenny Schmidt. Our staff also includes Maggie Penman, Chris Benderef and Cara McGurk-Allison.
你可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注我们，并在你当地的公共广播电台收听我的故事。如果你喜欢这一集，请给我们写个评价。这有助于其他人找到这个节目。我是香卡·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
You can follow us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and hear my stories on your local public radio station. If you like this episode, give us a review. It helps others find the show. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注我们，并在当地的公共广播电台上收听我的故事。如果您喜欢这一集，请给我们写个评价。这有助于其他人找到这个节目。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。